So it's not just your
interest in the oceans or space.
You've touched and been touched
by engineering and technology.
Yeah.
And there was a lot about the
cameras you used for Avatar.
But you go farther
back than that.
Well, yeah.
I just love engineering
and I love solving
hard engineering problems.
And I love working with really
smart engineers in a room
and trying to do
something that hasn't
been done before,
like make a sub
that can go to extreme depths.
You know, there were materials
problems, electronics,
batteries, all sorts of things
that had to be developed
that were actually
hard problems.
And you know, I just like that.
So Charles, he likes
solving problems.
So he would've made
a good scientist.
He would've made
a good engineer.
He would have been a
good just about anything.
He could've been somebody.
But that got me wondering.
OK, what kind of preparation,
what kind of thinking
must have gone in to
motivate him in 2012 to make
the first solo descent to
the deepest place on Earth,
in a submarine that he
piloted and co-designed.
- Wow.
- So you know where he went.
What's the deepest
place on earth?
The Marianas Trench.
Mariana Trench.
Thank God.
I thought you were
going to say my fears.
Almost 7 miles down.
Almost 7 miles down, off
the coast of the Philippines.
And so I asked him about
that record setting dive.
Let's check it out.
So what motivated you
to go to the bottom
of the ocean, bottom of Earth?
You know, the funny
thing is that I've
been asked that a lot.
And it occurs to me that a kid
would never ask that question,
because a kid would
know, you just got to go.
Why wouldn't-- a kids--
You so dissed me in
that moment right there.
[interposing voices]
As a culture, we start
to think like, adults.
- I want to be a kid again.
- I know.
Exactly.
So a kid would say,
why wouldn't you go.
It's there.
And you haven't looked yet.
So why wouldn't you build a sub
and get in it and go and look?